hey guys I'm Ryan right hey guys I'm
Selim into it
so we're checking out a video today a
special Mother's Day video what happens
when kids hook their moms up to lie
detectors so let's see how much as my
mom is a wonderful liar
she had me convinced that I was actually
a famous baby when I was young that the
Philippines worshiped me when I went to
the Philippines I found out it was the
exact opposite I was banned all over
because of a [ __ ] fried banana it's
ridiculous
we're just gonna go around the
midsection don't ask anything that's
gonna like incriminate it okay Herman
mom yes seriously I'm you picked your
nose today okay here we go
when you answer a question this machine
is gonna tell us whether you were lying
or speaking the truth William oh no mom
have you ever broken the law um yes
was it smoking-related yes have you ever
done drugs before what do you mean by
drugs there was no pie just a few times
really yeah just a few times marijuana
LSD
that's about it except the truth no
divine laws you guys liar I told you the
first time you're going to smoke weird
is going to be in our house and I'm
going to be watching it and coke did you
drink oh yes keep it you know Oh mom and
I can't look at you when I ask this but
at what age did you lose your virginity
it was um nearly 21
16 drivers license and we just yep have
you ever sent nude pics before never
that's a truth not even Polaroids why do
I have to say the guy took one of me in
high school
I was wearing my mother's coyote socks
long coat and I was nude I feel like
you're before the time of them sending
nude pics but have you ever taken a nude
picture hmm yes you fix yeah that's
cause he doesn't know how to use the
camera on her phone and I've got a role
played before in the bedroom you're my
son you definitely asked me questions
like that I'll ask you this is why
ability one heavy rider one-night stand
yes tell me jokes two or three hmm try
again lady have you ever had a threesome
no that's a lie are you happy but she's
so young the way they look yeah do you
look as good as you when you're young or
no nobody did like me you know what a
MILF is a what a mom I'd like to what
consider yourself a mother other people
like to have the answers yes truth have
you ever wanted to sleep with one of my
friends yes counselor yeah that was cute
have you ever stooped through any of my
stuff that asking yes recently did you
look at my phone the other day when I
left it at lunch yes yesterday mm-hmm
mom have you ever sneak through my room
yeah what was the grossest thing you've
ever found in my bedroom do I have to
say it on camera yes Becky sheets what
kind of dirty
nighttime admissions
you wish that we were doctors okay now
I'm offended
did you want either of us to be a girl
no yes
well mate it's gonna be better if they
ever I think so
why because of this video things gonna
be funny it's just the best mother's day
ever
it could be better like the fact you
never give money really all gonna be I
don't like what you're saying or how you
saying oh wait never dismissed is old
John I'm straight killaby I come out
here dronin block some drugs nobody now
hey well I think I heard the lie
detectors just like yeah that was really
adorable I want to see more yeah is
actually interesting it seems like the
best way to get like your mom to talk to
you actually
if I do that to her she would just
straight-up be like you were adopted
like stupid I know my mom is like
impossible to get answers out of she is
she brushes past every question gives
the most vague answers like it's in pot
I don't know [ __ ] about her past simply
because she just like either doesn't how
to explain it or Never
exactly yeah so I don't know anything
about her so it would be cool to hook
her up to a lie detectors we should so
do that should be our thing that we do
or we should just get a machine and tell
them it's a lie detector that way there
that they feel like they have to tell
the truth you know did that this is
Jimmy Kimmel yeah
that's my favorite thing
ever since like Meet the Parents it's
always like the parent doing it to the
kid so it's interesting to see you do to
your own mom isn't funny I liked in the
beginning when he the guy found out that
his mom smoked marijuana okay I didn't
know
it's interesting seeing some dynamics to
like you could feel like with those two
sons who liked you know felt like their
mom want them to be doctors there's some
tension there but then there's some
other ones where you're like the world
just like fun
yeah that this is really they really
love their mom and this is fun the
heavyset black guy and his mom seemed
like that he like really wants approval
from her and trying to get back at her
in some ways it's interesting no she
doesn't seem happy to be there at all I
think you'd be really interesting to see
more of that actually because it is it's
a good parent usually will lie to their
kids about let's yeah you mean you get
your parents who are really honest they
asked are very you know very personal
questions yeah some questions I wouldn't
want to know the answer to know that one
mom who's just seems like a total [ __ ]
mom not to be judgmental you'd like the
one who is like did you ever have a
threesome have you had one-night stands
oh yes I was like they look like sisters
yeah you know yeah so I wouldn't want to
know that about my mom I mean my mom was
considered like one of the really hot
girls in the Philippines when she was
young so I imagine she got a lot oh yeah
god I'm almost kind of the same way she
said like I don't know everyone's going
to dater I think your mom and my mom had
a threesome with a celebrity maybe okay
my gosh Jack Nicholson Christopher walk
whoa I can't go further with his joke I
don't wanna go I don't want to make fun
of my mom having sex and I'm not doing
it anyway happy Mother's Day to any
mother who watches this channel there's
like a 90% demographic here that is all
mothers if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects sally
has channel the Salamanders salva
channel
a video with my mother for tomorrow's if
you want to check that out and subscribe
you should be you and your mom making
out but no yeah that was disgusting
never like I don't even like hug my mom
that would like right that's you make it
hot put down requests people and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
hoping to get enough followers where we
can get product placement
Wendy's Wendy's is delicious
they have cheeseburgers french fries and
I actually know of this mom named Wendy
yeah he knows titties yeah yeah okay
well hold us back let me tell you about
when do you feel that if you're watching
you know which one do you are nothing
it's so gross
I don't even know when yeah Adam eats
eight wherever eh hey guys a new
subscriber mr. full-on gamer love this
[ __ ] keep doing what you're doing
because no doubt you'll be hitting seven
digits soon cough shoutout pls cough but
seriously good [ __ ] it's kind of likes
talking about [ __ ] I could tell
something about you Adam you know this
is a Mother's Day video I'm going to
talk about something very personal about
you I know that your mother was kind of
abusive to you she would [ __ ] on you a
lot
it was crazy what she would do to Adam
[ __ ] on his chest his face as punishment
and reward is very confusing now use
really obsessed with [ __ ] and now he
Adam ate that [ __ ] yeah beets there's a
joke there somewhere happy Mother's Day
to all and to all a good night
and shout out to my mom Joyce hope
you're watching this video mom she
doesn't I'm sorry if you did it and
shout out to karel well that mom i hope
you're getting drunk right now
she palette is doing a bunch of cocaine
off of some black ox take care she does
like blanket